i hate like i hate fighting because i
know you i don't because i i really do
and and i know you maybe a lot of people
don't don't
believe me but i'm gonna try to explain
the best i can
in every in every jobs there is no
perfect job do you agree that there is
there's
no perfect job that you like every
everything
about it it's impossible
my job as a professional athlete and
mixed martial art
on 365 days i've i fight normally when i
was very excited i used to fight twice a
year approximately
not more than that i never wanted to
more than that because i wanted to
stretch especially
you want to stretch when you're champion
because it's better for
for advertising the the also for uh
longevity and everything so more time
more money more business wise and
everything and longevity
so about two twice a year in 265 days
there's two days that i hate the most
it's the day that i'm fighting
it's freaking unbearable the feeling of
uncertainty that if you don't know if
you're going to be humiliated you're
going to be the victor we're going to be
the loser it's i care so much about it
that is freaking unbearable
as much as i try to dismiss it
it's unbearable however i like the fact
that i'm a free man on my own bus
i do whatever whatever i have i have
access to certain things like vip stuff
that most people
don't and my quality of life
uh the money i didn't have it before now
i do
i love my job i'm very happy about my
job but there is
thing about my job that i hate the most
is fighting i freaking hate
i love the study of fighting i love the
science of it how i'm the tactical the
physical i love to train i love to walk
in a room i
feel strong i know if something happened
i'm the man even though it's an illusion
because with a bullet and nobody is
faster than this
but i like that lifestyle
i do it for the lifestyle for what it is
i don't do it for the fight i freaking
hate to fight i had this talk with
robert mcdonald at one point i was like
hey why are you like fighting oh i guess
i like to fight so you like to fight
it's like [ __ ] no
i don't like to fight and everybody in
the room turn around they look at me
like i'm crazy i'm like
you guys are all crazy you think i like
to fight in a cage and one million of
people maybe get humiliated knocked out
or die are you crazy i don't like to
fight are you nuts
i like to win when you win you're it's
the feeling is
unbelievable it's so good that it's
worth
this yeah but i hate it man
do you hate the day of the fight up
until the fight but once the fight
starts
how do you feel once it starts no no no
no no no when it starts
it's gone all this stuff all the
anticipation's gone i like i
hate the day the build up the day the
day and the closer you get to the day i
start
i love it but i start to hate it more
it's like a build a head that build up
like a bubble of hate
and by that time that it's time to
freaking walk out this
like the many
seconds that it's time to walk out and
like bert watson used to be that guy
used to kick out the door
sir you ready right now he's not there
anymore unfortunately
i i used to like verdict
so i used it's like a bubble that
build up in my stomach that hate hate
hate and i freaking ate i'm even in the
locker room before the fight
and i [ __ ] ate it my last fight i
it's crazy i saw my my friend
eamon got knocked out and i go at the
dinner
everybody is like dead people like this
and and i see where something is wrong
is it what's wrong
as i they told themself before i get in
the room don't tell them that
that amen lost don't tell him he's gonna
affect him
so i get in the room and my friend eddie
who wasn't there when they
when they tell each other first thing he
says to me he's like in the room say hey
amen
you say okay physically is that yeah
it's okay and everybody's like holy [ __ ]
so emma and last i remember joe defiles
uh mickey gall loss so i go in my in my
locker room i see one guy with the ice
bag the other guy is all [ __ ] up like
this and i'm like man all my local room
lose man holy [ __ ] i freaking hate this
job man
then i'm thinking it's like everybody
tried to to make me think like oh it's
going to be good
it's one of my agents like don't worry
it's going to be fine as i was like
it's okay man don't talk to me like this
i choose be here i'm i'm a warrior and
so go go sit now it's going to be fine
like i want to be a warrior i don't want
to be like
you know yeah oh it's going to be fine
don't worry and they go like you know
they go like this yeah yeah like when i
found my news the first time
they go like this guy they grab me like
don't worry john's gonna be fine they
look each other like
like he's fighting but he was islam
everybody on his head holy [ __ ]
i'm feeling like i'm going to a like a
summer like a cemetery like
someone just like so i'm in the locker
room everybody freaking knows i'm like
damn
then i'm like shake it up i go in the
bathroom by myself i go i go look at
myself in the mirror
and that's what i do before the fight i
used james lounge
theory who james nudges is a they say
that the
the spirit can dictate your mind you say
you're you thirsty
your mind tells i'm thirsty you grab the
water and
your spirit can dictate your mind but
your mind can dictate your spirit
so i go in the bathroom i close the door
people think i go to bathroom to piss or
whatever but i don't
close the door and i say i said now i
see a lot of negative [ __ ]
i go i go in front of the mirror and say
i say to myself say
i say try to convince myself like a kid
you know like
i'm the greatest i'm the strongest and i
think
i think of it looking at me and i'm this
i'm beautiful i'm strong i'm this and
then i
i'm faster i'm stronger i'm gonna win
it's like this young guy they lose but
i'm gonna show them what the
the way to do it you know maybe they
they fail but i won't i'm gonna show
everybody how it
should be done so i come back in the gym
with the glory to show them that i
achieve it and that's how it should be
done
if they're gonna follow me man so i try
boost myself
open that door go go back i still hate
my job but i'm a different person than
when i get
in the door so i play with mind games
like this
with myself all the time it's stuff that
i
that that try to change your attitude
it's very important for a fighter
because
the confidence is a key for a fighter
some guy they do stuff very basic in a
fight but they do it when they do it
they do it so good then they believe in
it
they don't hesitate and you have no room
for hesitation in a fight you go 100
and when you go 100 with confidence
that's when the magic can happen
you know what i mean if you have the the
the skills
but you don't have the confidence is
john says that you have the skills and
you have
no confidence it's like having money and
you don't spend it that's what john
denaire told me
but if you have the the confidence
without the the skills
it's not good too it's like a dream that
cannot be achieved you don't have the
any way together but if you have both
that's when the magic can happen i
remember when john john
says that to me all the time so you have
the skill and you have the confidence
and confidence is not a choice is that
is
a confidence is not is not a state of
mind is a choice man
you can build it in your head when
something bad happened you build it and
work
try to work on your person to build it
this is something you can work on
yourself you know
and that's why i've been doing yeah it's
like
all these other things you're saying
it's there's there's no one
answer to how all this is done all those
pieces have to come together
all those pieces have to be together in
order for you to be able to just go out
there and do it but i love the fact that
you say that you don't like it
i freaking hate it man i hate it
probably even in the locker room when i
got there
when i got there that night and like
every other night that i'm fighting
ask my agent like ask ask even for us
i always tell him i look at him as like
so what the hell i'm doing here what the
[ __ ] i'm so stupid i should have oh my
god
and they we always laugh at it because
now
it become at the point that i know i
know it
people say with experience do you do you
become
more courageous do you become how do you
say do you lose the fear
you don't lose if you never lose a fear
you learn how to deal with it
you accept it before i didn't i did not
accept it in my earlier fight
like matt use my first time i found my
use i i man i was fighting this monument
say oh my god i didn't sleep for the
week man i came like a freaking zombie i
was like oh my god
like even in the stair down i couldn't
even look at him i look up
like this it's like i couldn't imagine
myself i knew
i was going to lose the confidence was
not there
i have the skill is not the confidence
so it's it's very important the
confidence you know is for a fighter
confidence
it's very important that's why you have
guys in the gym that are very good in
the gym they get into a fight
they shitty fighter they're king in the
gym they're going to fight
all that stuff crush them
you have guys they're normal in the gym
i've seen guys in
in ufc they're fighting ufc they
freaking bad
i can't say for the respect but i spar
with them and they
suck when they fight they do stuff that
it's amazing i'm like
i didn't even know it that wasn't his
repertoire of technique
that he just did a category or something
i'm like man it's amazing
i even knew he knew that right because
of confidence man
and when you have both the skill and the
confidence like you see like jon jones
man is magic man you go there
spinning freaking elbows and stuff like
you don't hesitate to go man yeah
yeah rodriguez is amazing and stuff like
that
it's just beautiful to watch you know
and i really like that the new
generation man is scary as hell oh my
god